how it ends is an American disaster film
starring Theo James and Forrest Whitaker
the story revolves around will making
his way back to his girlfriend with
their father after a mysterious
destructive force sweeps across the
country throughout this video I will be
discussing the film in full detail so
obviously they'll be heavy spoilers with
that out the way I'm definition and this
is my how it ends video for how look
I'll just get into it now
after all flights are canceled will and
Tom embark on a road trip after making
several stops along the journey they
encounter all manner of people from
thieves to escaped convicts and grieving
families during the trip
Tom's lungs collapse and will must
perform a needle thoracotomy this is a
medical procedure that allows decompress
tear within the lung to escape and from
this Tom's breathing returns to normal
unfortunately the attacks continue and
when the duo are accosted by a gang on
the bridge
Tom succumbs to the wounds that he has
received thus far and dies at the scene
the car also breaks down and will uses
the remaining gas to set Tom and the car
ablaze and continues on foot a car with
a family stops by while he's walking
here Idaho and they offer him a ride and
he shows them the way to his father's
house will finds it abandoned and
decides to give all of the supplies in
it to the family in exchange for their
four-wheel drive which allows him to
continue his journey as well gets closer
to Seattle he sees that the city is
almost completely destroyed and fines
are not left by Sam with an address he
visits this address and finds Jeremiah
and Sam and they stay in the house and
catch up for the night however will
become suspicious of Jeremiah because
he's been checking out wills car and
acting very strangely when confronting
him he discovers that Jeremiah is in
love with Sam and they've developed a
special bond because his daughter was
dead this of course leads conflict and
Jeremiah tries to kill will only to be
shot by well in self-defense
we can draw it's pistol from here we see
a big cloud of smoke and fire approach
them and this causes will to get Sam as
they drive away from the cloud we can
see that it's clearly destroying
everything in its path which of course
is a very tense moment the couple
driving off with the engulfing cloud
behind them but moments before reaches
the vehicle the cloud appears to slow
down which could signify that the
disaster is now at bay
however the open-ended nature of the
film leaves a lot of questions and I'll
now discuss my theory on exactly why
things caused it was the destructive
force that rages across the country and
how it ends is never truly explained
personally I believe it's a metaphor for
the government's inability to properly
communicate which causes fear and panic
we have seen that fake news and humans
jumping to conclusions often leads to
fear of hysteria and due to the lack of
information on the devastation people
may trample over others in order to
survive a cataclysm that seemingly has
no end the sparse clues that do appear
and how n suggests that some of the
observed events are due to a volcanic
eruption the u.s. West Coast possesses
two super volcanoes the Long Valley
caldera and California and Yellowstone
and Wyoming and these two volcanoes are
considered to be one of the five biggest
threats of humankind with the other for
being asteroids nuclear war disease and
global warming
volcanoes caused huge volcanic eruptions
and during one it's important to keep a
power grid working this obviously hasn't
happened in how it ends and explains why
the network's fail and air travel has
become impossible I definitely think
this was the case in the film but as
always I'd love to hear your thoughts if
you have a different explanation comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video please like it and subscribe
to my channel I create videos like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of films I recently
discussed eight amazing things that you
definitely missed an infinity war so
make sure you check that out linked at
the end of this video thanks again for
taking the time to watch this and I'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]